guardians of the galaxy vol 2 crashed in
the theaters with all the action and
comedy fans of the franchise have been
waiting for
not to mention dozens of in jokes and
callbacks to both the previous film and
comics if you didn't spot them all don't
worry we picked out some of the most
interesting and obscure Easter eggs and
guardians of the galaxy - fair warning
major spoilers coming up star Lords
shirts guardians is full of tiny details
which is part of what makes the films so
fun to watch but one of the weirdest
questions in Guardians vol 2 got
answered before the movie even came out
several of the trailers show Peter quill
wearing a shirt with a weird alien
looking logo to most people
it was just cool looking shirt but two
Guardians super fans it was a challenge
as one Reddit user figured out the
graphic on the front of the shirt
actually says gears shift in an alien
language the language used on a keyboard
in the first film exactly what that
means is still a mystery
but eh it's pretty cool regardless the
cronin connection as rocket and yondu or
portal jumping across planets to reach
ego we see a ton of interesting visuals
like the legendary Stan Lee talking to a
group of Watchers but one other cool
glimpse we got was of a barren alien
planet with two hulking aliens beating
each other up those guys look a lot like
Cronin a technologically advanced
militant race of beings that look sort
of like big humanoid rocks so what's the
connection well we've already seen a
Cronin in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
and Thor the dark world that guy got
blasted into gravel but Thor Ragnarok
will feature another Cronin Korg who in
the comics becomes Hulk's ally chords
roll and Ragnarok is still unknown but
now that Guardians took the time to
feature the race of rock men we have to
wonder what scored one of those figures
fighting in guardians or with that shot
simply put in as a bonus for any fan
paying close attention with no bearing
on the rest of the MCU Cosmo returns one
of the weirdest characters from the
comics has now made an appearance in
both guardians films we're talking of
course about Cosmo the spacesuit a dog
who runs up and licks the collector and
the post-credits scene from the first
film
Cosmo showed up a few times before that
in the collectors of collection and just
like Howard the Duck
this guy was back for another round of
the post-credits scenes of guardians -
at first this Easter egg seems like a
simple callback to the first film but
what you may not know is the Cosmo is
actually a recurring character in the
Guardians comics and cartoons and he
does a lot more than lick people when
they're sad Cosmo is a well he's a
telepathic space dog who acts as head of
security for nowhere that's where we
meet the collector in the first film and
he's incredibly powerful for example in
San Jose imperative number two Cosmo
single-handedly killed the Hulk with a
mental shockwave and he once went
toe-to-toe with Adam warlock and came
out on top this is one Doug you don't
want to mess with and while we're
hanging out on knowhere celestial
trifecta egos reveal as a celestial was
pretty big news and guardians - if you
didn't know the Celestials are an
extremely powerful cosmic race they're
basically space gods as ego himself said
in the movie but this isn't the first
time we've seen a celestial in the
guardians of the galaxy film it's
actually the third time the one most
fans know about popped up in the first
guardians when star-lord and his troop
went to nowhere to meet the collector
while explaining the Infinity stones
collector shows them the video of a big
metal man with the purple one blasting
people into dust
carriers can use this civilizations like
wheat in a field that guy was basically
a photocopy of the Marvel comic
Celestials and the third celestial well
it's in the same scene they were all
standing on it in it to be exact
know where the collectors little black
market mining colony is the severed head
of a celestial calls no
the severed head of an ancient LS do me
so when ego reveals he was a celestial
the idea should have been pretty much
old hat the fans who've been keeping up
with things the whole time yondu's big
orange fin Michael Rooker is yondu looks
pretty close to beyond do at the comics
he's a big blue guy it's a pretty hard
look to screw up and yet there is a big
difference in the comics yondu's had
been is a big orange mohawk it's not the
slim tangerine curve of the first film
well until yondu replaces his broken sin
with a prototype version and guardians
to a prototype that's a bit bigger and
much orange er er it still doesn't come
close to the glorious head spanning
monstrosity of the early comics but
yondu's new look takes him one step
closer to his comic incarnation the
Crystal Frog yonder is little crystal
frog practically had a subplot of his
own in the first guardians although most
people completely missed it he got
another cheap little bubbles like this I
like to stick them all in a roll on my
control console I can't tell if you're
joking or not yeah that thing well
yondu's got his frog and he kept it with
it before he goes into the climactic
slide in the skies of xander that little
frog is sitting right by his hand and
when his ship crashes on the planet the
crystal frog is the only piece of
wreckage yondu picks up out of the dirt
unfortunately yondu bit the big one but
he still has his frog in guardians to
during the overhead shot of yondu's
funeral pyre his body is surrounded by
ornaments of his life and one of those
symbolic trinkets is you guessed it that
little blue frog we can only assume that
the Frog has been to hell and back again
at yondu side so it's only fitting that
that's where it remains when yondu is
blasted into space and a million
Technicolor bits thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel let's check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]